look okay so they do all have to go into
one scene perfect thank you
Alexi
um yeah yeah cool X streaming is back
working great it was broken
before happy 720 on a
Thursday we are whoops don't need to
that we got code review to do for bet
whenever he's back and in the
meantime we can look at some experiments
let's do
that oh there he
is
cool that is
here I will take a quick look at
experiments in the meantime
never made it to exercise
ridiculous man you got to do your
exercise not
optional okay so
here we got our carbs red um
log I basically want to see if carbs is
getting better over time during the
sweep and it's a little tricky because
like some of these points let me see
make sure this is showing yeah okay so
some of
yeah so some of these
points right on sweet progress uh they
might be over here or something which is
on the Paro
Frontier I'm trying to think how to see
this
it's not going to be linear so I can't
do
like the plots are only 2D
right I think 3D is a stupid thing to do
but yeah it's only 2D
it's kind of late let me just let's just
make sure I'm not being
stupid I doubt I am being stupid but
let's see if there's an obvious answer
I'm
okay so I'm not being stupid this is
just there's no obvious answer to this
H actually you know what would work is
the
coloration is there a way to color the
points
um you know hot to cold or something
then you'd see over
time so you get scatter
chart hey bet
okay so this is a chart that I can make
but not a chart that I can make in
Neptune I
think let me test now let's do your code
review thing right um You can do that
another time I think that it's I think
it's correct anyways
okay
good let's get your code reviewed so you
changed a bunch of stuff on
Duro and you fix some things in Blaster
right like to get Blaster just added
that'd be a nice thing to
sure BL that's
fine let me figure out how to do this
audio let see if this
works hey
bet yo yo I think that this setup should
work um
cool lots and lots of cool lots of
progress this week lots and lots of
progress this week
um yeah been
busy yeah yeah I'm super busy too I
don't know if I made a lot of progress
but uh Blaster will be refactored
shortly fix this let me just check to
make sure I
haven't we got quotes for the new
machines we got
uh ma major stuff done for two academic
labs
excellent how how much uh how much is
one of those
running what the machines uh about
5600 I see is that with like a ryen or
yeah that's top end
everything
cool okay uh let's figure
out what to look at codewise
uh I'm probably just going to do this
live yep do it up I got uh where should
I look join your stream on sorry I'm to
join your stream on X here real quick X
twitch YouTube whatever do this [ __ ] no
no I'm in there on Twitch but I want to
be it in on uh yeah let me know if the
audio works there and if it does then
you're going to want to mute it because
you hear the Discord audio oh yeah I've
already got
muted hopefully it's not echoing and
[ __ ] but yep I sound great we sound
great okay good audio is working
wonderful cool uh right minimize
that so where should I look here pop
this [ __ ] out uh you're it's p PR just
look at your P request oh there just go
to uh here uh puffer puffer
lib yeah yeah that's
fine okay let's
see uh let me make sure this is covered
let me let me move this I do like I'll
do this for
review
cool okay
and okay so somehow
this is
down 6 700 lines okay actually that's
kind of about what I expected so it's
not a lot sorry there's a rebeat there
so this is only 40
lines
okay yeah we don't really care too much
about the read I know
um okay so let's see what you did
here got rid of Malik good you shouldn't
be malaking
render uh I got rid of the
c i you kept it on step but you might
want to put it back we I added this to
all environments see reset cstep and C
render uh so I actually I figured out
the source of that it's not a problem
with our with the code at all it's an
utterly stupid problem with cond C
compiler which like a bunch of people
use uh there's no way that I can see
around it so I changed it in all
environments even though it's a really
stupid fix so cond cond C compiler yep
it's horribly broken code and by the way
even if you compile even once you get it
working the compile like 3x lower than
with normal GCC so I have absolutely no
idea what they're doing but uh I added C
underscore to everything just the step
render and reset functions are
enough yeah why uh why it so I I don't
recall compiling with with that compiler
though
uh you were getting that bug somewhere
else the the bug the bug exists
uh it exists you know
all G GCC just I tested it I tested it
with GCC and I tested the old versions
of GCC as well on W on
WSL uh not on WSL but WSL should be the
same as native Linux I think it's I
think it has something to do with WSL
because
specifically uh specifically it seems I
know I know linky had a problem as well
uh he was the one that discovered the
bug and it's a compiler bug either way
yeah but a lot of people don't have it
too so yeah I I just I did it anyways
but um you got to be careful because I
don't know what compiler it is that's
breaking but it seems that it's way
slower as well uh and I I messed with
the flags a whole bunch it was also
injecting a bunch of garbage compile
Flags but I couldn't reproduce like I
could not get it to be fast even with
good flag lags so I don't know anyways
the compilation
itself why is client now called game
State client is a
client oh whatever it's called game see
okay you can you can rename it if you
want it's the same thing it's a game
State
client that doesn't make yeah that
doesn't make
sense yeah I call the client a client um
logs okay
net and then you got rid of seaing oh no
here seeding okay it's there it's there
still
okay and
reset hey Spencer we're reviewing BET's
uh
code tank uh hello you're on stream by
the way if you're in
the
client yeah you don't really need to
guard like this but
whatever it's not not the worst thing
because I guess this prevents python
users from double freeing it's not the
worst okay so we
have some key press
adding is this re is this rearr it
should be the same yes it says but they
both had L as well
okay then demo demo
is linear
[Music]
lstm same
thing and then per test
cool it's
fine uh we'll check .h
last try check the
pi it's just added white space and
log like R have the rewards buffer yep
so that matches that's fine and
yeah yeah it's FYI actually it's not FYI
uh turns out turns out I actually need
that that's that's vital for the the the
code to
run as as you saw in the file you got
back
slashes
huh I don't know me this 28 I see no
it's this many lines of changes it's
actually shorter than before
Spencer it's way short pull this they
actually cut like 600 lines off of
it it should be a reasonable size now
it's more than
600 um I'm curious to see what you cut
off
go so I just see additions like adding
logs okay oh no the logs were there
before you just it's not not back not a
backslash that's that's
a well I don't know what the hell it's
on to the it's on the next line because
of uh the
playing
format
what how does that make wait is this a
backs slash so that you can put the
comment on the next line I'm confused no
just look like like I can't show I can't
show I just show
you if you actually look at it it's the
format of did not me okay don't I do not
suggest Auto formatters cuz they do
stupid [ __ ] like
this like literally you can't like the
best formatting is just doing like basic
manual perceptual grouping of
[ __ ] yeah that's obviously how I had it
before let's just paste it in
the general chat there we go say you
could see what it looks
like General General
[ __ ] okay if you wanted to do this what
you would do is You' put the you'd put
the pound Define with the 90 right on
one line and then you put the comment on
the line above it with the
space you definitely don't do this
[ __ ] yeah again that was not manual that
that automatically yeah look even who
whoever this is even knows it's a line
it's a line it's a line limit like
exactly also we're live uh X YouTube and
twitch YouTube neural MMO X and twitch
jars
5341 I stream the vast majority of my
Dev and code
reviews this is a Google Google Google
CL tidy format with if you're in the
voice chat you are on the
stream um content in case you wondering
state so you got rid of some stuff let's
see got rid of a bunch of I wish I could
I wish this freaking window worked cuz
it doesn't show me anything at the
moment
here
restream there we
go now I can see the darn stats and I
have chat window and stuff cuz my
overlays they the OBS uh overlays like
the chat window and the stats and stuff
they all break okay
good so let's see what you remember
moved here
um you still have all these
indices
and yellow digit off SC minp
X so you somehow removed a bunch of
variables from the game State yep bunch
of variables gone bunch of do these live
somewhere else now no oh cuz this is the
renderer they do not live somewhere else
they're they're in endur now right yeah
well they were in endur all and they
were getting copied over okay yeah yeah
so you sto doing the weird like
functional copy [ __ ] good I stopped
doing the weird functional copy [ __ ]
yeah okay you do not need to duplicate
variables in multiple places that's just
eror pron and stupid okay that's good
that's a good fix um and then but
they're also fewer variables in here
now yeah there's I'm curious as to how
you got rid of
these uh let me see
here like some of these are constants
like car with and car height yeah any
anything constant is now a constant so
that's up top now yep or car car width
and car height weren even weren't even
being used I don't think I might have
made those removed a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
that like was like from
yeah okay and then this like gear
threshold okay yeah these are constants
okay I told you this so you pulled all
the constants out to constants and
removed all the random [ __ ] that you
didn't actually need yes
correct
okay sure you can have an enem I don't
ever see the point of having enems but
you can have one
sure thanks
and
then the [ __ ] is all
this it's a it's an asset map you want
me to put in a different file I can do
that no that doesn't need to go in a
different
file because they're all on a Sprite
sheet and these are the dimensions they
are all on a Sprite sheet and those are
di that's fine yep that's totally
fine how do you know what the index is
to
use H how do you know what the index
is how but just making this spreadsheet
and
then okay well we'll look at that I use
a I use a spreadsheet uh Creator and I
very
painstakingly uh place I mean when you
access when you access
them okay this is um before I was
mapping it to an Eno I just mapped it
directly you said this is this is better
the reason that this is better is
because the reason this is better is
because you had stupid [ __ ] like asset
digit 0 through n where this is really
like it's going to be like digits and
then plus like an offset or something so
having like enums for this is insane um
so yeah I don't
know I'm curious how you're mapping it
when you have literally one of these
sheets like I would think that this
would be like rectangle background map
and then that has 15 16 things and like
Mountains map has 16 things or whatever
so it's easier to index but we'll see
how you're
indexing
yeah so I probably would have made this
like what is this four or five separate
Maps but if you have a good way of
indexing it's
fine uh client where' the client go
all the prototypes are gone good they
you don't need prototypes all the
prototypes are gone correct good yeah
you should not need
prototypes especially not for like a
single file game
project um it's pretty pretty ug
car get furthest Lane are these new
functions uh no those are not new okay
so you just moved them around a bit
okay uh I don't know why the log but
buffers way the hell down here but
whatever Aggregate and
clear and you did uh you did my new
login style good yep that's fine that
saves you some lines
good now in nit well where did nit go
and it's under free
allocators so keep keep going
it'll be down okay so you just moved it
line 425 and now you have this net
function which sets a billion variables
but I'm hoping that I'm not going to see
the same code twice because I saw it
twice before you're not going to see
you're not going to see any duplications
at all there are no so there's a bunch
of obnoxious initialization here it is
all necessary like it won't train if one
of them not initialize properly like
which is interesting because C zero all
the things that are zeros but whatever I
guess you use this to reset as well
don't
you uh yes I am dual purposing it that's
okay so that's use it to zero that's
fine but where where where where would I
be celing everything it would probably
go in I mean it would probably if what I
would do is I would probably stick most
of this into reset instead of in in it
because it's like you're calling in it
from reset which is kind of weird it
would be better to just put the stuff
that you need to in it once here and
then the stuff that needs to be called
every time goes in reset um that would
probably be a bit better but at least
you're no longer calling everything
twice CU I think before you had yeah you
had everything in reset as well which
was obscene so this is at least
substantially
better quadratic yeah okay this stuff
rodex i' I've already reviewed your code
so I'm just looking for like major
refactor
changes um
y yeah so I would still probably stick
like the if you want to keep messing
with stuff I would probably move all the
stuff that needs to be done on reset
into here um and here's the thing it all
needs to be done basically on reset uh
like all of this stuff is well yeah but
I it's weird to have reset call a knit
like you're supposed to call a knit once
and then you call reset whenever you
need to reset so like if it all needs to
be done on reset that just means that
like you don't really have an inip
function just have a reset function um
yeah so I guess it could be all moved to
uh but I imagine some of this is going
to be like some of these are constants
right well to be fair probably you could
take out the the ones that are constants
could probably just be taken out none of
those are constants wiggle speed wiggle
length are these initial values only
those are initial values only none of
those are constants all constants have
been removed from here's a constant
timings the gear timings I think they
need to be initialized
though a Conant there's no way that's
not con I got you you you read the code
it's Conant I got you you got
you putting it by the other gear
time it's that's fine to declare it
locally
like it's better just stick as a
constant if it's a freaking Conant but
whatever um
because then you don't need the extra
variable in the struct confusing you
either but whatever yeah yeah Ro Ed X um
this is the same as before that should
be the same there car in X
okay check
Collision why are there so many diffs
everywhere I guess it's just because the
C code moved spots and get up not smart
enough it's the formatter yeah oh
[ __ ] formatter man don't use those
things well you won't see any weird
indents at all now yeah you shouldn't
need a formatter to not have weird
indents speaking of which are these two
space
indented uh is the whole code Tu space
indented now yeah dude [ __ ] that no no
no re if you're going to run that thing
rerun it to four this is this is this is
before this is before I figured out how
to make it the
correct we're not doing two like there's
like six places you have to change
change it in in a PS code okay go fix
that [ __ ] because it's it's it's already
fixed I literally controls it's
done go update the pr we're not doing
two space [ __ ]
scale nearest car
info all right this is the same this is
the same code as before um Addy Car hold
on is there more [ __ ]
here oh yeah yeah this is
because I think I told you this that
there was like some weird redundant
logic is it yes or is it the same hold
on it's mostly the
same it's about the same
length Okay I see update time
okay good so there's some small
refactors
curve step function is gone so I assume
that's lower
down this looks to be the
same it's so hard to tell because the
[ __ ] format is just destroying this
like you see don't don't use those
things man they're [ __ ] not useful just
don't use the like people are going to
tell you you need all these fancy tools
I I write code in [ __ ] vim and like
it's fine and I don't use any of these
things and it's fine like these things
do not like these things are not your
friend you don't have to write your code
in Vim but like Jesus like don't don't
let tools like go just automatically
restructure all your code
not only does it [ __ ] up the diff but
look at how look at how like all the
Hideous [ __ ] that it's done all over the
place yeah like nothing is going to be
better than you just like paying a modum
of attention and like you know manually
putting spaces where they're reasonable
and stuff like that it doesn't take very
long you just do it naturally as you
code
yeah like basically I can promise you
that you will never do the indent thing
like you you'll never screw up your
indent after a while that's just like a
newbie thing it's really not that
hard I do that in Python like I'll screw
up like an indent level like once every
several months and then I'll spend a
couple minutes feeling stupid that's
it it's a lot harder to screw up with
four space inste too as
well I agree I don't like topace yeah
don't let don't let people bully you
into using stupid tools that [ __ ] up
your code it it was it wasn't that uh
VSS code like was pretty pretty obscure
with how to change how to edit like
basically I was using these things
yeah I tell you the only the only tool I
find legitimately useful um and to be
fair it wouldn't even be that important
if I actually like bothered use an LSP
but like I find super M nice for single
line Auto completes cuz it saves typing
that's it yeah it it is nice same thing
as copilot or whatever else just don't
like don't tab whole functions and stuff
like that's it's a nice typing buff
that's it yeah I think Super MAV might
be smarter than go pilot I don't know if
it's smarter I think it's just
faster it seemed a little more intuitive
at least I
was uh just writing a uh a file to
analyze do you have the free version or
the pro version I have whatever was on
pu
box okay you're probably using my
key it it's fine it was just there uh I
usually just I type Vim press enter and
yeah there it was that'll happen on a
shared box whatever
um okay now here's
for you would you would have gotten so
much more out of this code review if
this if this shitty Auto refactor had
not just destroyed your death I'm just
saying
um cuz like what the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do it's like slice and dice all your
code he does make it hard to hard to
tell what's changed doesn't
it yeah I'm not a magician like I can't
just
tell
um it's like I guess this is the same
probably right
like yeah they're going to be some
minute details that are uh hard is it
still
train yes Joseph okay I Pro I I I
promise that uh not only does it train I
have I have trained a new model that
does work the weights are in there the
curves are about the
same yeah it should be good okay so I
know so I you moved all the functions
around so you don't need prototypes good
um you removed like the crazy duplicated
stuff uh from the client State you
messed up a couple of names rename stuff
back to client and stuff U put the C
under score ship back it's stupid but it
fixes
cond
um let me see what else did you do let's
see load
textures digit
indices background indic what the hell
is
0 through 15's backgrounds 16 through
31's but oh man so let me just explain
what you did all right so you went and
constructed all these
offsets because you made one texture
array right correct okay look now you're
actually G to get something out of
this because this is
stupid it's better than before but it's
still stupid
you're getting very direct code review
at this hour it's fine say whatever I've
had I'm a little grumpy I had a four and
something hour dentist appointment today
where they just ground my teeth for four
hours I will I will I will not be
offended I'm not good at coding okay so
look this [ __ ] right here all right this
is asset like this is asset mapcore BG
all right and this [ __ ] right here is
asset map map
and this [ __ ] right here is asset map
digits right and this is green digits
and this is yellow digits and then you
don't have to compute any offsets at all
because it's just going to be you know
background of index it will be 0 to 16
right mountains 0 to 16 digits 0 to n or
10 whatever okay so and it'll be the
exact same
performance well hold on isn't this
slightly more
compact no it's not this is flat ma
because because then you have all this
[ __ ] indexing logic at the bottom to
compute the
offsets so when you have like blocks of
16 indices like that there's no reason
to flat map it like
that you can have like four or five
different
Maps it's not more compact because you
have to do all this indexing
Shenanigans like you wouldn't even here
let me find it for you
all right not only is it more
confusing but like where is it where's
the stupid
thing okay so not only is this confusing
as all hell but you don't even need
these variables like these variables
would not be part of game State they
would not
exist because you wouldn't need the
indices because it's like if you just
wanted digit three it would just be
three you wouldn't have to worry about
these offsets so all this [ __ ] like
right here like most of this code just
gets
deleted rip there you go so that's this
is how like if you think about your data
structures a little bit you end up with
less garbage to have to do housekeeping
over okay clean up fine make make client
fine close why is there close client and
a
up don't don't make useless
functions this is all just close client
this there's no reason you would ever
call this other than when you close the
scoreboard yeah like look all this this
like digit next you wouldn't need any of
the
scoreboard yeah so all this asset map
stuff would be a lot easier cuz this
current asset index X you wouldn't have
this it would just be like score digit
minus one or
whatever they
completed let's yeah so all this
indexing stuff that's going to confuse
you would be like this would all be
cleaned
up Victory update mountains
cool
mountains car index
Road asset car index car asset index so
we had to compute get car texture index
you had to do a whole bunch of stuff for
this color
then yeah it's kind of fine to have a
function that looks like this this is
fine yeah that's the render clean
no that's fine
I mean it depends how long the function
is
right it would be very long
yeah if this were like a 300 line
function I would just make it a function
with sections I would agree it's not 300
lines well the question is could it be
lines I don't know no we'll see how much
shorter kits when we remove a bunch of
indexing or [ __ ] but uh it'll be a
little it'll be a little shorter but
probably not a ton shorter a lot of that
a lot of that is the uh the
score but you see how like you know your
brain can only handle so much code at a
time so if you write more code than you
need you don't not only do you have to
deal with that code but then you have to
add more structure to break it apart
because your brain can't handle that
much code so you end up with even more
garbage code so this is why like
programming skill is exponential because
like if you do stuff in the simplest and
the easiest way possible not only do you
avoid
the redundancy but you avoid the
structure to support the
redundancy yeah this is a this is a good
Improvement uh I will say this is a good
Improvement I'm being very harsh uh not
really not not really what I would say
is so what I want you to do is first of
all take your stupid auto form matter
and rerun it back to four spaces commit
that and then the next time you show me
a diff give me the diff from that
version so that it doesn't destroy
everything again gotcha okay I've
already already done that so yeah so
make sure you do that and
then uh if you depending on how much
more you want to keep refactoring so I
don't know refactoring your code is a
really damn way good way to learn how to
get better at stuff so I personally
would suggest that you keep doing little
bits here and there on the side if you
get bored you know by all means do other
projects but you know keep coming back
to it here and there um because it's a
really really good way to improve is
just like polishing your code until it
no longer hurts your eyes
um yeah the indexing the most egregious
thing the most egregious thing I saw was
the way you're doing indexing that's the
worst data structure that you
have as for like is there other
redundant logic I don't know I literally
don't know I would have to like see the
code put together after you know you
make these changes and fix the spacing
and everything else and then I would
have to look through the like not the
diff I'd have to look through the whole
source file and see if I see anything
else to simplify right yeah because how
even even I can't tell [ __ ] from like
looking at just these diffs I guess
technically look technically I could do
where is
it technically I could do
this and just see the
latest file okay so now we're down to
lines yeah get rid of this [ __ ] this
ridiculous um
fine I generally like don't put all the
strs together I see you put all the strs
together I generally put the methods
that go with the strs with the strs so
like I put my logging with my logging um
yeah I saw that it's just like it's kind
of annoying otherwise
yeah so these indices are just going to
be gone right all these indices are just
like
gone
yeah I even this like even
this like you don't need indices for
this index index yeah
but be locally defined locally defined
variable though right what yeah it'll
just need to be locally defined or you
don't need the freaking indices at all
because look these These are only there
because you have offsets into a giant
texture map like you don't need to it
backround because this is just going to
be 0 through 16 0 16 0 through 11 0
through 10 or 0 through n like they
won't even have to
exist I yeah I I understand it okay so
like a lot of the stuff in this game
State I don't know what these offsets
are
I guess this is a height offset so this
is
legit H yeah the um the the drawing of
that is super complicated yeah I can buy
this is a
pain okay and then you have really bad
all this [ __ ] okay this is a big ass
struck um yeah it's all the end logic
yeah I I don't I don't understand how
this is a like like in the format I
don't understand how this is like oh
this is the way that the format should
be it clearly looks like crap it's very
confusing to look at well you learned
something don't use those I think these
are constants
I'm pretty
sure um they might be and this one gear
Gear speed threshold sounds very
constant to me this sounds constant to
me so I mean this is a big struck there
are a few things that can get out of it
but yeah it's a big environment it's
going to be a big struck whatever
um I don't really I don't really like
the idea of like breaking apart a struck
just for the sake of breaking it apart
if you're only going to use it once so I
think this is fine it's fine to have a
big struct as long as all the stuff in
the struct actually needed right like
I'm is this OB siiz of isn't this a
constant as well isn't this defined up
top
um possibly I think there are like five
or six variables here at least that
don't need to be here um
OB size is definitely
constant I feel I feel like the top as
well I feel like I removed it there was
an issue or something oh you can see I
put like all the constants at the top
now the exception here is if you're
going to put like the rayb rendering
stuff down with the rendering that's
fine I usually do that but I'd put like
all the actual constants up at the top
enum is fine here I'd probably just
pound a fine but en is
fine this is now going to be like five
or six different asset
Maps yes and you're GNA you'll actually
save lines because you won't have all
the index in garbage I will refactor
that first we will we will see logs yeah
i' put this back up with the logs right
and add log I put my Logs with logs
breaks it
up okay and then this allocate free in
it is good most of the init stuff would
probably go and
reset
yeah yeah gotcha this a constant
totally
um gear time over total
time Min hold on
so so what I'm pretty sure this is I'm
pretty sure that this is a very fancy
way of calculating a constant it is I'm
I'm almost certain like I'm pretty sure
you could just calculate what this is
and then write as a constant because
yeah yeah just looking at just looking
at it again now that you've yeah like
all this stuff pointed it out I did uh
you know I basically what I just used
the litness test to see what was a class
and what wasn't like is uh is the
variable being changed at all if it's
not then it doesn't need to be a
variable so and initialize that's
fine you have in both Pathways here you
have
zeros you take all the shared variables
that are going to be zero either way and
you put them outside the statement and
then you delete them from the
statements they're like small things
like this all over the
constant the previous daytime
index total day duration there's no way
this is a constant
right well what's SEC so I think you're
Computing some constants that that is
being that's just a placeholder variable
for computing a
thing but I think that the thing is a
constant whatever the name's the name's
confusing so that's why you're so reset
I think reset gets pretty big and in it
gets very
small most
likely yes we can I can I can switch it
to you the um and then reset doesn't
call a net uh the the only the
only difference here is let's see an it
is getting a
[Music]
seed um
reset is not so for the reset
count uh when reset count is zero then
it should uh use a random seed for the
in it
um you can figure that
and a lot of this looks better except
for the god awful two space indent like
what the [ __ ] is
this
like yeah I personally didn't like that
either I know
like it's funny to me that this not only
does this like thing Auto format it auto
formats in the worst possible
way yeah like you put the plus the plus
goes at the start at the new line it
doesn't go at the end so you can
actually see the operation at the start
like and then you don't [ __ ] align
stuff like this to
the I don't know this Auto for not only
is like does that does this show you
like not to use an auto formatter but
this Auto formatter in particular also
sucks but it was basically
default with VSS code
this is nice I use your your better
coding as well uh I like this
Captain that's all
configurable
yes look it's some people like them some
people don't it's my code review so I'm
going to be opinionated I hate the
things oh he's saying configure
configure it sanely like yeah I know I
still don't it's possible to use I still
don't think that there's anything that's
going to just make your code better than
putting a modom of effort into just like
manually putting sane perceptual spacing
and alignment and stuff so Joseph are
you ready for this your your preferred
the way your code looks your preferred
code could probably pretty readily be be
you know programmed to an autof
formatter that way it it will always it
actually be kind of tricky it' actually
be kind of tricky if you'd have to you'd
still have to do like uh spacing between
sections manually and
stuff oh I don't know I a lot of stuff's
kind of
contextual uh I mean whatever like the
thing is I'm going to write my code that
way anyway so the auto formatter doesn't
really help
the uh the cars you remember you were
saying oh you have cars that are that
are disappearing or or warping that is
intentional Behavior I did modify the
way that it it works so it is
uh basically invisible uh it is
intentional behavior
um the cars the cars should move that
that come behind you if if you are going
slower than them they should not frash
into the back of your
car so that's what you that's what you
you see them moving uh I made the the
spacing more uh
more intuitive so that it it it moves
more intuitively so it seems less like a
warping enemy
logic like when does the curve left when
does it go St when does it curve right
could I simplify this block a bit a
bunch if I really thought about it
probably is it okay
yeah the here's the thing it was it it
started out very simple and there there
are like several very slight nuances to
make to make it be like like the
original
code that caused a large amount of lines
to be add there's so much stuff like
look this is use this here here here and
here okay this is playable area diff and
then each of these becomes one
line man I was so so proud of remember
what was there before those uh those in
fact these are constants so you can
literally put a constant at the top
that's playable area diff and then those
constants were not constants uh before
oh yeah you've improved stuff I was so I
was so proud of them you've improved
stuff for
sure I'll give you that you definitely
improved
stuff I'm still going to keep bitching
at you though until it's like I
mean so far all the criticisms
valid eventually what's going to happen
is you're going to stop making like
weird style like weird style errors and
we're actually going to be able to talk
about like logic structure and things
that actually
matter hey and do we know yeah he said
he it does
work but like you know it runs like so
does a burning bus
right oh come on it's runs a little
better than a a burning bus it's good
and it's improved it's down 600 lines of
[ __ ] I mean it's not it's not like
particularly slow either speed wise no
it's
good but if you didn't look at this code
for six months and then you came back
you'd be very
sad uh yeah depend depending on what I
wanted to change if I wanted wanted to
change any of the rendering stuff yes I
would be very
sad uh I don't want to touch that I
definitely don't want to touch the
quadratic bezier or the road Edge to be
fair I'd be I'd probably be pretty sad
looking at like my neural MMO code or
whatever but I wouldn't be sad looking
at my snake code right it's like
anything that's
midsize when you review in wor it's up
to Jesus [ __ ] Captain well the thing is
I know that you're you're an experienced
programmer so I'm going to find way less
to [ __ ] at you about
um but that also means that the
standards are higher I might still find
some stuff to [ __ ] at you
about we'll say that's a solid
environment though but by the way 3.5k
lines of code is larger than neural MMO
so you got to ask is it more complicated
than neural MMO including all the fancy
rendering right the the answer is you
know it's probably probably not I I
don't know how how you define
complicated all right look at this look
at this thing and look at all the crap
that goes on in this this is like three
this is like around 3200 lines I believe
okay to to be fair there's an difference
between replicating an already produced
program and riding one from scratch I do
want to say that I mean there there was
freedom in both of
these so like all this like freaking
item system level system profession
system experience scripted enemies all
this fantasy rendering all this is like
3200 lines of code all
right you you've also you've also
written it not in a C++ Style
I nobody told you to write stuff nobody
told you that you have to write like you
have to split everything up in a billion
files are shaders included in that the
shaders like 100
lines just maybe 3300 just wanted to
show show your shaders the shaders the
shaders are freaking okay first of all
the shaders suck because I suck at
writing shaders but if you want to see
these I think they're even in the
resources folder because of uh
they
areer hey you've got that weird
siming yeah I think that was for comp
compilation
Shenanigans okay I think they're in here
cuz it's like there yeah there's an
annoying thing about loading these okay
it's 50
lines right that's the
Shader that's
it it's a pretty pretty slim Shader you
got there this took three days
nice one bro
shaders no the Eminem
joke the shaders are not fun this was
this is actually this looks short but
the thing that this is doing is actually
fairly complicated mapping uh P mapping
pixels to what tiles they're on is
actually pretty damn complicated because
like the freaking assets for this are
where the hell is is
sheet it has all the different lurs like
of all the different grass textures and
all the different variants of all the
different Waters and all the different
grasses and all the different tiles that
snap together so pain in the
and are you sh something on
Twitch yeah yeah I'm on Twitch YouTu
you're live yeah you're live so this is
actually oh I'm sorry I missed both 2858
lines for neurl Mo 3 so Les this is all
in this
file I think there's an additional
Simplex that's like 100 something
lines um but that's about about
it tile Atlas oh yeah I put the tiles
here that's it so that's it I don't do I
even use this I don't even know if I use
that I guess I do but that's
it so things can be
compact also that was ported from that
is the literally the first like low-l
program that I wrote this could be
substantially better like cuz i i b
basically I wrote that in scon and then
I ported it one to one to see if I'd
actually like written this from scratch
sanle it probably would be a little
shorter all right there you go so no
excuse yeah it's nice very
good okay um that is review for that you
haven't fixed blastar yet right no blast
you know blastar is in a in a state of
flux but I have condensed it into the
regular some pretty short I think I gave
you pretty short list of things to do on
that um there there are a couple that
are a little okay
tricky fair
enough uh do I have other code to review
at the moment or what are we doing I got
may I also have experiments that I can
that we can look at um I don't actually
know what to do with
these but
let me check this slack real
quick length and width Constance for OBS
you know it's kind of weird that they
haven't gotten back to me
yet I kind of like I took a day and I
kind of like solved a bunch of their
stuff
um
whatever did did did you help him
earlier with his uh invite
IR Robo code stuff yeah a few messages
on stream as all okay Robo code's going
to be
awesome make everything as Crest seemed
really cool
like a python
script oh no that's silly you don't golf
your code the point is not literally to
minimize lines it's not to golf your
code it's just to make it as simple as
possible
which usually means that it will be
shorter but when you start golfing stuff
and getting stupid lines that are
impossible to read you just you've you
started optimizing the metric and not
the thing you actually care
about some of the tiny grad code is a
little too
golfed for
I know people get like the functional
programming
bug oh than you doesn't like code
comments oh linky doesn't like code
comments you don't like code comments
linky not entirely I just feel it's
extra I have to look at yeah yeah you
you you you keep all that [ __ ]
straight uh some comments comments some
if it's like I guess really heady but
for the most part if you just name your
function and your variables right it
kind of explains the code itself this is
true yes you have to know what the [ __ ]
you actually have to know what the [ __ ]
you're doing to do that though
um but yeah usually configure stuff
out so this is supposed to be decently
fast if the cube
Shadow
speed oh these are dis Ben
marks it says number of environments I'm
confused if it's number of environments
or if this is the number of bots inside
of one
environment which I think that's more
likely yeah because look if you if you
see oh hold on rough
and well it says number of environments
it doesn't
say I think it means like that many
different robots but it's I don't see
4,000 robots here uh true it's possible
that the rendering is not but is it
4,000 different environments is it four
is it one environment with 4,000
robots I know I know what you're asking
and I do I want to
get we need like this is what we need we
need this like 90k FPS the scene that we
we fiddled with today only got it it's
like 11,000 SPS is
terrible oh what are these the are these
numbers with just like your just basic
outline and then not doing anything or
are they well I'm running puffer but the
thing is the m is taking up 95% of the
time so whatever asking about these
Nvidia Benchmark
numbers like how how how did they RL
games library with headless I don't
freaking know
now this is just the time for the
environment but the thing is like yeah
we're running training but our training
is so fast that it doesn't
matter
right anyways I got something working at
the very
least twitch folks
um so okay the next thing I guess I
wanted to look
at so I've been sitting on this for a
couple days and I want to run some new
experiments but I've got
it's annoying to me that you can't set
this inside
of inside of
Neptune I wish you could just set
the you should be able to set the dot
colors uh like how are you
gonna arrange the dots or what what's I
should be able to map them
to uh to like a heat map like the hot to
cold or whatever yes so what I would to
do is I would like to have along the
time I'd like to use the creation time
to do hot to
cold and then what would that would
happen is I would be able to
see on this Paro graph when the runs
were made so if it starts off hot and
then gets colder right but if I see all
the blue the blue dots are on the parito
front then it's getting better over time
right yeah so what you'd like to see is
all the blue dots here and all the warm
dots over here true but I can't [ __ ]
do that because they don't let you color
the plot so I'm trying to see if I want
to do like more offline analysis I guess
I mean the alternative thing is they did
email
me I don't know how hard it would be for
them to add
that I it shouldn't be that hard they're
using like they're probably using like
plotly as a back end
right I I I I wouldn't know uh some
things seem to be easy to add but uh
maybe I should maybe I should set up a
call with them or are you know
deceptively difficult because they're
contacting with someone and they're
using a
certain nah this is probably just plotly
or vager or something or
something SE Seaborn Matt
plb it shouldn't be that hard maybe
their code sucks and it's like hard but
I'd hope it's not that
hard I think that's a pretty damn good
suggest that they might actually take
it's worth scheduling a call with them
cuz I would love to not have to do all
my analysis offline like it would be
nice to just have that
here I would agree with that um yeah
that'd be really good for hyper pram
sweeps um okay so I will tell them I
will talk to them about that Al so why
do I only have 57 runs
here
um what the heck is on what's what with
this there we
go
so yeah here are runs I mean I can see
that we have a lot of good runs here at
the least this is better than our random
search so this is our random where's it
random
search I have lots of experiments but
like most of them are bad
I think we're well set up to
do additional stuff from here though
um I would like to start a sweep of some
type
let's look at our environments and see
what was like what we want to
use here's here's here's the play Joseph
you uh you generate your heat map during
during the run and and then you you
report it to the Neptune can't
really no I don't think you can do that
not really
like the uh I can do it offline very
easily because like I can just download
the data right and I can do it offline
pretty
easily maybe I'll do that to start
with well you could you could have a you
know you can have it grab it each time
uh after a Run's complete you know it
can it can grab it and update the the
all the runs counter for all the runs
image
what what what you doing I'm just
thinking how I want to structure stuff
like we don't have all the new machines
yet but I I want to start thinking about
like how we're going to set up our
baselines for Science and how we're
going to like go about
stuff that's the real engineering right
well it's like structurally how you
support the
research yeah because like I don't want
to just do breakout and
pong
obviously some of the environments kind
of take a little bit too
long at the
moment like actually let me look at
breakout for
instance so
like the parito front a breakout
here in order to get a good run you kind
of need to run it for 20 20 minutes
which is nutty 20 minutes
why does it just take a long time to
discover oh I can get the ball above the
blocks I mean let's look oh I can break
out or is it a matter of it having to
play the second game as well so this is
what the curves look
like whoa
intense
um yep it's all over the place
I don't know why these
are oh These Are by
steps
heyer by time for for loading uh we're
trying
to trying to engineer breakout to
be in a good Baseline state to perform
research on it
like some of the M's are just too
slow like to train I guess that just
means that
like it's not a terrible thing well I
mean like look at these curves like
these curves are like a lot of these
curves are very
reasonable like look at this this is a
very reasonable learning
curve yeah that one looks nice and this
is very like they're a little spiky but
like for the most part they're very very
reasonable the endpoint estimate should
be very accurate as
well I guess we are not sweeping bat
size and stuff at all in here so we're
kind of missing out
on a lot of the potential
speed
parameters and a lot of what carbs can
do maybe that's a good thing to do
because this is kind of a good case
study for that if you think about it
right cuz right now we're like we're not
really giving
carbs enough room to find fast
stuff um cu the batch size perms are
fixed I mean all Bally the ideal sweep
is you have everything in there well
yeah but
that's it's hard to get that to
um I mean this is the stuff I this is
the type of stuff I want to be thinking
about um I've just I've had to catch up
on a lot of work for labs and clients
and
stuff
yeah I I I got even more to do on that
but I know you you need an
employee yeah I mean I can onboard a lot
of the open source folks to science side
stuff Spencer and Captain are both now
getting to the point where they're
qualified this is pretty I mean it's
pretty pretty straightforward
stuff it isn't it
isn't well puffer Li so yeah
running the stuff is not hard setting
the stuff up is not hard thinking about
what to actually run and why
is yeah that takes
yeah I I think that it would be a good
idea to try to bring down the wall clock
time of
breakout I think that would be a useful
thing to do as a case study to figure
out like what parameters matter there
and it's possible that we end up
actually training at like a slower step
per second even in order to do that yeah
we could we could also have you know
have sweeps for optimizing different
different variables
too uh these let's look at this optimize
score right no they optimize they
optimize both um they it's a Paro
front when you what your your what is
your uh your setting uh in the
config well it optimizes score but the
thing is carbs takes into account time
so it will try to find like the best
score for each amount of time so it will
push it will push for
faster right so I'm saying I'm
saying you can get interesting results
sometimes from optimizing a different
variable ver versus versus score I don't
know about that I I I have
well that's the variable you care
about well yeah for it's it's a little
trickier for like breakout doesn't have
that many parameters
really yeah so yeah score
yeah but there there are there are going
to be different environments that have
different things you care about like for
instance for Blaster you don't want the
enemy to get across the
screen uh MH that means it's gone you
know you have to dodge at once right so
you could optimize for minimizing
that well that's just a proxy
reward it is well you could what you
should do is you should tune that reward
way but you still ultimately care about
your
score true but does the model respond
to stuff ma maximization of score versus
there may be an easier way to like the
proxy may be yeah but you still measure
you you measure the thing you care about
you can optimize in whatever you still
measure the thing that you care
about yeah
true and and score should should be
going up when it works
well so
train let's find out so by default
breakouts actually quite
slow
240k so let's
see if I do One update
Epoch and what the mini bat side the
default settings for this are
Oban um
16 and then was it it
32 then let's
do let's see so if I do
not does autot tune
work hold on PA only has 1024 hold on
why is pong
slow there defaults just suck or is
there something running in the backround
here
there something taking hold
on what the [ __ ] is
running maybe someone's run or something
that's your that's your personal one
though
right okay this is stuck in the
background
somehow
uh what is
pill slf I just do
[ __ ] suspiciously pill slf
python uh Dash F Jesus
breakout yeah yeah yeah okay breakouts
at a mill now perfect so if you run 4096
M you get a
mill which is what you would expect um
10 Bill run going overnight very good
so the somewhat obnoxious thing about
this
I really like the fact I really like how
I have mini batch size
specified
where you have to explicitly put it
because it prevents you from shooting
yourself in the foot in various ways but
the thing is when it comes to hyper
parameter
sweeps um batch size and mini batch size
are kind of Linked In A
Way true so you can't you can't have
like mini bat side that is greater than
batch sizeer will stop
you well but if you do it in a sweep
it'll just cause the thing to crash I
would like it to not even be sampled I
don't really like the idea of switching
the mini batch size parameter to a num
mini batches parameter
though yeah let me see what that would
look like in the
code shouldn't shouldn't shouldn't carbs
be smart enough not to give it crashing
stuff uh it'll learn eventually but it's
still not
great oh yeah well I computed here hold
on I computed here anyways and then do I
use this [ __ ] it's an assert no mini
batches you're going to compute one from
the other anyways
yeah you can set it as
failed but it's better if carbs just
can't sample invalid parameters in the
first
place I could switch
it from mini batch size to num mini
batches
and then when you go to sweep
it then it's just a
uniform uniform int from like say 1
to8 and then you get to set B
size pretty well independently
bad I mean this will totally screw
random search but you just can't random
search batch size I
guess oh why would you random search
patch size like is that even a
thing it's just if you didn't if you
were not using
carbs I'm trying to think if I want to
implement this right
now time is it
it's only
nine only nine Joseph has changed oh I
did get up at like six
something it would be good because I'd
be able to launch something at least
yeah let's let's do it let's just do
this now we're going to do the quick
version of it um I'm going to do it on
the ablation blanch Branch so I don't
miss anything
what exactly is puffer logging
bug uh you have to divide by the number
of update Epoch and the number of mini
batches but there's a little bit more to
it than the original bug report so I
haven't fixed it
yet but basically our losses are
probably going to be increased by a
factor of of update
epox there's a
bug a small logging bug
yeah well does it have to do with
printing
logs uh it has to do with the magnitude
of logs
only okay
it's not a huge
deal okay I think this is actually
enough uh let me
there we
go mini
that could
oh
one I
can't it's kind of hard because
resample so I think it's still good that
I did the mini batch
change um
but I yeah I still need to read that's
fine I just have to Res
six so then this is going to be like
this out
to and we'll
do mini
B it's going to
be
two one
eight is there anything else I want to
sweep in
here num
this is going to be this gonna take some
time to get
right yeah sweep so not this is a pretty
substantial change to some
stuff is uh is this Neptune
sweeping
yes Neptune does not have a sweep
feature so this is just manually queuing
jobs
I want to add early stopping as
well yeah I was going to mention
this is gamma supposed to be that low
what like 0927 gamma
oh that's the those prems are tanked
they'll get sweeped
over
okay yeah we'll get better
prems cuz it'll it'll probably be pretty
stupid like unless oh yeah it'll be real
stupid so we're going to just mess
cing some
sweeps everyone's on everybody's on
stream right now yeah you're on stream
welcome welcome which is fine it's just
so you
know I just stream all the dev by
default cuz why the [ __ ]
not just getting in a very quick arm
workout before I call for the night I'm
envious if I lift any weights apparently
my tendons will tear off my bones so I
got to wait a few days yeah I
remember I did get a I got some
adjustable I got some 70 lb adjustable
dumbbells for my room for the next
couple weeks and I have like a full what
brand uh I think new Bells I got um oh
nice nice I've also got I've got a full
gym showing up in a few weeks I got a uh
big ass rack and functional trainer a
deadlift platform and like 700 pounds of
plates coming so you did it you did it
it makes
sense I need I just I need to get my
health back it's just like freaking
brutal the last
month yeah having the having the home
gym is is a very clutch I enjoy it yeah
oh you have one too nice yeah I love
mine yeah
dang we got a bunch of we got a bunch of
fit people in the chat everyone's
everyone's all all swole D I've lost 15
pounds in 3 weeks it's like I was
full I was like 190 probably 133% body
fat that's more than me
LOL 5'9
yeah
so I'm out of shape I should be SW I
don't really have an excuse
but
uh do it reg yeah do it regularly over
any anything else just doing a thing
regular know yeah I just oh
okay there's some weaves Blowing by my
cat's freaking
out some what there are some leaves
Blowing by a window and my cat saw them
and was like freaking out because it was
I don't know in exciting her prey
instinct or whatever yeah that that prey
drive yeah gotta go eat the
thing at least catch it because that's
that's fun yeah
yeah um the push-ups I do 20 push-ups
every day no matter what
yeah I'm trying to get three workouts in
a week with my wife it's got okay so far
but it's good though because she gives
me she gives us good workouts because
she's do that for a
living
true doing doing anything that is
generally better as long as you're not
hurting yourself than doing oh sure yeah
you know nothing even if it's like
pretty slow
and obviously it has to be enough right
you
can't most people don't get exercise
from just walking like for half an hour
some people do
but well I mean no walk some walking is
better than nothing even that it's
exactly that that is literally how I
started my
exercising is
walking but I mean even if you're like
in shape like like walking is always
going to be like you know what I mean
even if like yeah sure like running is
better than walking but walking is
better than
sitting well the walking was not not to
ease into working out anything it was
specifically to give my body some
prompting to to begin to to adapt to be
be strong in the places strong and
flexible in the places it needs to be in
order to handle the stresses of actually
exercising so I'm like cardiovascularly
mentally much more capable than my body
is capable physically so I end up
injuring
myself I
gotta Joseph do we you have a way to
currently oh wait I guess never mind I
was thinking you're using carbs but
you're not using carbs right now so
never mind I am using carbs he is using
carbs oh okay then um in your kind of
homegrown sweep thing you have a way to
like explicitly fail a sweep yeah like
tell carbs a okay cool just making sure
so I kind of missed it before like is
there a reason or maybe this is what
you're doing right now are you kind of
writing some logic to PreCheck that the
hyper pram sweeps are like I don't know
valid and then like if not like telling
carbs it's a fail or
something uh there's just one there's
only really one one Bad setting that you
can do which is this
one he's
programmatically uh programming I guess
for lack of a better term the batch many
batch and Min batch sizes so that they
don't screw
up so this won't be an issue on like a
buffer box but I know at least for me
like the way I do sweeps um and I'll you
know probably switch over to whatever
like puffer has like once it's like uh
far along but but um I run every like
run in a new process and that actually
turned out really nice because like I
only have a 380 ti so only like 12 gigs
of vram so sometimes like when I was
before sweeping over a batch of mini
batch sometimes you know like the sweep
uh with carbs would suggest combos that
wouldn't fit uh in like my vram so then
it would just like give me a CA air and
then I just tell carbs like hey like
that's a fail and then it keep going so
yeah so literally this is all you have
to do like the batch will always fit in
your vram and if it doesn't there's an
offload option um literally you just
have to check the mini batch isn't too
big and you're good which is this lineup
wait what's the offload option there's
an option to offload the entire batch of
data to the CPU so you never store your
batch your full batch on
GPU I see that probably way slows it
down though right time it not always
doesn't need to be slow super slow
though interesting not
always um let me see if this freaking
works
so actually this doesn't work because
carbs suggest
arbs wait
suggest ARS
must specify
value or
distribution hello hey hello hello we're
just uh designing a cool super cool
sweep toting to very tired I'm so this
is time
steps oh yeah so let's just get rid of
that for now CU I'm not I'm too tired to
implement that tonight as it turns out
we'll do the cut off
tomorrow benser did you have any more
luck uh like did you finish your sweep
or are you doing some other
stuff uh I I I went ahead and stopped
that sweep it looks like it capped at
around five climbed and it never it
there were a couple runs that were
looking like they got like 5.2 5.3 but I
think that was just like random
luck um why are you
sweeping so I'm going back to now
messing around with rewards and uh Hey
seeing what I seeing what I can mess
around with there I haven't really made
too much progress I only kind of ever
since I kind of hopped in the Discord
I've just been kind of uh testing a
couple things here and there
gotcha yeah I feel like the expert word
might work pretty well but we'll see I
think that's a great
idea I'm wondering if I'm going to do
exploration should I nuke all the other
things and just do like exploration plus
like probably keep literally dealing I'm
literally just looking at exploration
papers tomorrow just add just add add it
in for a
client uh I mean you could you're runs
are so fast I guess you can try all
sorts stuff so I mean you could just try
adding what you got try something and
then see if it works if it doesn't work
then like as long as I have reasonable
hypo parameters it's fine and keep on
messing with
stuff I do think though that reward you
added where I think it's like every step
they're like or basically every step
they get a reward proportional to how
high they are I think that's kind of
Jank just because
like um I don't know they're constantly
getting rewarded like that's almost like
two
what's the reward expain out I I have a
Jank reward
where it is going it rewards it every
step based on how high up the mountain
it high up the tower it climbs so the
intention was that so it doesn't regress
by Falling Back Down the tower and stays
on a certain level to figure out how to
climb above it that's Jank yeah no you
should you should just get bit of reward
for going up what every time it goes up
a level and give it a penalty for going
down a level that's it that's the
cleaner way of doing it you you can you
can in further in going up in sequence
by rewarding up in sequence or up
without a down in between uh that
doesn't work for this game though for
that specific thing well oh yeah because
sometimes you do have to go down you
have to like sometimes it doesn't matter
it still figure it out just do the thing
that I said give it just Define define
reward for going up to find a reward for
going down and sweep the component
values why could devise fromy exist no
Romy is Garbage I'd say just see George
see all of the things that tiny gr has
tried to do I'd say just Yol it uh they
literally it's like an AMD can give you
the chips for free and they're still too
expensive unfortunately that's true is
that Aaron yeah
didn't yeah
hello hell of a day had a chat with Jeff
earlier today how's that going
good we starting
stuff uh as soon as we get uh the other
stuff out the door he was like then by
all means boot it out the door best you
freaking can for your sake not mine I
don't care I I really don't care but
like it's like I'm trying to look out
for you here um I got you
oh for good night
guys see you later T night someone asked
a question here I see what H I'm Jason
are you a real
person why I see Jason asked a bunch of
weird questions like just randomly every
so often I've never seen I've never seen
Jason before so no I've seen Jason
okay does this
work I being stupid ises this
work let's see if this
works I hope this
works I mean that's pretty cool it's a 3
minute
run is
fast uh it's slower but could be
for a second shut up oh okay well I it
was still spoling up um there so I got
all these
parameters in uniform update
epox I mean how do how how do we do
early stopping we'll see if this
works does I don't know if the number of
M is getting
swept done
num well it's on there you just don't
know if it's working I I bet you it
isn't let me
see break
full yeah I bet that's not working let
me kill this real
quick okay and let me figure out
cuz that's like the really
important I want to just get this to
running go to [ __ ] to bad oh and what
there's a break point in here how the
[ __ ] is this
not there are multiple break points in
various
things okay well I I don't understand
where it might hit after mode oh sweep
okay so I'm not running sweep as why I'm
running
sweep it's probably probably why you put
the breakpoint
in let's see
this okay so
args ARS n okay that's
cool and then when we
do that actually looks good to
me right the parameters that's
picked it looks good and then because I
didn't
do yeah so let's just
remove move
this
these okay now let's try
this and this should be slower
num
M ARS train num
bug that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
um I don't have unless I
Mass this is
fine welcome back t
suggest wait
4K if name in AR k
all right
oh wait
self oh that's
obnoxious I
what are we working on fixing uh car
sweep real quick with en
params
um TR
en okay so I think I need to go
through
for it should
be
in
args P do
items go through
items
yeah
okay whatever we don't have policy ARS
yet
Branch good so this I think this now
works
good Okay cool so let's see what the
parameters are on
this and whether
this this
SPS one four mini
batches 1
M three update
EPO BF
coefficient think I want to kill this
one last time so I can change a couple
small
things
um I think we've
learned well I want to play with BF
coefficient some more cuz there's some
janky stuff going on but I don't want to
play with it right
now so I think what I want to do is I
want to fix VF
coefficient 0.5
Max graad
Norm I don't like
this I don't like that this is a
parameter
efficient I don't necessarily
like the max rorm parameter
either what does it set to in clean ARL
okay so we get rid of this and now we
just have EP Horizon
EPO Lambda Gamma entropy learning rate
and then the scale
PRS I think this is
good I think that this
is this is an
improvement what we do is we run this we
hope that this doesn't crash
overnight and I think for
see let's see what parameters this gives
us 1024
amps and then we get train
frams
of 65 okay batch size BPT Horizon
yeah 0.5 value
function for many
batches Lambda Gamma learning R I think
these are
reasonable so now the question is going
to be of course we don't have early
stopping early stopping would help a
lot
yeah
um I can Implement that
tomorrow early stopping would help a lot
we'll do that tomorrow cuz I can specify
like you know if it's not if you don't
have 20 score and five minutes or
whatever kill the
run but I think that this is going to be
interesting
because so here's the goal with this
right I did 100 runs of
carbs uh not messing with the scale of
parameters kind of just sweeping your
standard stuff
right and I get this nice Paro front
here the best you do is you get like 850
score in about 800
seconds uh that's more than 10 minutes
right that's almost 15 minutes it's like
15 minutes to get a reasonably good
solve on the
environment so now the question is you
know can we really tune this thing so
that we solve breakout in like five
minutes or
something and if so what does that tell
us right what does that tell us going
forward about how we should should be
tuning Our environments and such and
generally if we can get all of our
environments to not only run fast but to
train fast and wall clock time uh then
that really increases our ability to run
more and more
experiments we can really crank up the
number of experiments we can run and
then because I don't want to just be
running p and breakout right I want to
be running our full Suite of
environments um but to do that we're
going to have to get them training
faster in wall
clock of course once we get the You Know
M many more machines we can kind of work
around a little bit but
still we want everything to be nice and
fast and for some of these it might mean
that we have to take training speed down
to like you know 200,000 steps per
second um in order to get it to actually
be faster wall clock and that's fine the
horror 200,000 steps per
second we can lit we can get close to
200,000 steps second without a GPU on
most of our environment
are true we can literally do that on
like one CPU core for most of our
environments yeah puffer's
fast
yep I'm pretty good at making stuff fast
around
here okay so that's
interesting so this was a quick run
there's your curve let's
go it's a quick
run of 100 so we got in three minutes we
get 178 score and breakout on our very
first got a purito front purrito front
right
there you've you've you've simplified it
perfectly that that way no one has
to going to do have to guess or look at
the wrong
View should be quite good so the
question now right how fast how fast can
we Sol
LR so that's good then on X should go to
sleep in a second there's tons of stuff
on X I mean Space X just kind of did a
thing
but check rip ship 30 33
was wasn't that a lunch day yeah I don't
know when this happened we hit 6500
that's nice yeah 6500 is good numbers
got to keep going up here's the here's
the here's the
postmortem oxygen fuel leak in the
cavity above the ship engine firewall
that was large enough to build pressure
and exess of vent
capacity yeah I just need to move move
them to switch
I we stream it everywhere
TSS no I said I said now he just needs
to move the U audience to
switch no I don't I don't really care
where people watch they can watch
wherever I'm watching on X to uh to
boost him on X if it's even a thing it
might not be but
actually actually claing X is insane
what's
that actually cl's X is
insane I
mean I just watch on Twitch because I
have the same handle between here and
ttch is it that guy hi that guy that
that is something I also
do I'm notna use like not going to like
worry about what Google account I'm
signed into for the day it's too much
effort my twitch handle is good enough
my twitch handle Discord handle the same
for a reason good
enough two more months until I publish
something I get till we guess we submit
that paper and my name is revealed sure
Aaron what whatever you want to do is is
whatever sure we're gonna hunt you down
that guy terms will be the
same hunt him down Aaron actually knows
where I live where where I live now so
to talk to him about really like Ina
nerdy
stuff that guy you a g student
or I am who I am I know I'm an employee
out of place he's
a he's he's a senior engineer am I
senior engineer no I'm not not
anymore I'm going to Startup we don't
have titles that like that oh yeah you
don't don't have titles there's just
like CEO CTO and everyone else I get to
be you know if when you do your own
startup you can make your own title so I
get to be Chief puffing
officer yeah bet Pro of the puff no
unfortunately cp's already taken so
that's not a good idea yeah I'm just I
just do work I'm currently doing the
fourth rewrite of this code this week
but I think I finally got it I finally
have the idea down very proud of what
going
on that's good people are going to hate
me for this one though but it's gonna be
good I mean why would why would they
hate Improvement do they hate progress
is that it oh they're gonna hate it
because there's a bit of Jank in the
middle of it but like oh my God I spent
all week trying to figure out how to
deal with how to how to like generalize
our
tokenizers it's such a pain sounds
sounds like a pain
oh yeah I wanted to get this stuff this
guy's going insane but his stuff looks
good who Brian
Johnson why do I know that name he he's
gone like insane with the like social
media
marketing um what is what does he where
does he
work I mean he has this did you heard a
blueprint no nope this is kind of cool
oh there's the brain free guy okay so
it's like the guy who made P like the
guy who made
venmo
oh founder of blueprint Brian Johnson
this I
mean I thought it was kind of bullshitty
at the start but like the more I looked
into it this actually look pretty
legitimate he's got that work oh wait we
actually have a bunch of his products in
our in my office it's in the I mean
that's thing ever isn't that the guy
that like uses like his kids like blood
or like plasma that a
guy that's a different guy did he I
don't know okay could completely
different guy this guy just looks like
you think he's going to be a snake oil
salesman who's selling you supplements
it's funny he literally Brands his olive
oil snake
oil yeah I know I was like I I we have
that olive oil brand in our office I'm
like someone just found it funny and
bought it it's been there since I
started so
yeah I am actually going to try this
stuff
so I would like to figure the thing is I
wish I I would like to figure out how to
get all the biomarker
tests
um I mean you can but there's not a lot
of you necessarily to do a lot of the
testing it's sort of like okay so I mean
what do I do with the data like is you
see if it you see if it improves you see
if it improves after three months of
taking the supplements you know you you
can you
can you can test and test and test and
test it you've got a lot of data the
question is I mean his data is actually
pretty damn good though is the
thing perhaps is it do
anything what's what's his what's his uh
what's his acuan is is he like I mean
he's got he he like releases all of his
medical tests and he's like actually I
mean he's like actually it looks like
ridiculously improved his
health like to an absolutely ridiculous
extent right so I mean yeah if he's
doing all the all the all all these
tests and he I mean you don't you don't
really even need any special tests you
just basic
longevity routine I think I don't 26
GRS wait Brian Johnson he is the guy
that took his he is the guy that took
his kids
blood
hey long long time wait no that's not a
doctor I don't know yeah
he what the [ __ ] does this thing have in
it got a bunch of [ __ ] in it probably
it's PE protein hemp seed protein yeah
here's the thing where's the where's the
heavy metal
component no he actually he actually
tests that does he actually yeah he
actually does test that he actually is
very thorough on that testing um I would
I would hope so I'm happy to pay extra
for for not having a bunch that's
actually one of the things that he
publishes all the test on everything
it's funny because I live in a [ __ ]
super super fun sight but
yeah I don't know why it's freaking PE
protein instead of whey protein is the
only thing is the
base I don't think that's it's not a
complete protein as far as I'm aware uh
it's it's cuz it's CU sometimes for some
people animal Dairy
fats he's vegan but he's not vegan
because he's not re vegan for health
reasons it's just that's personal choice
but I wish the base of this the thing is
though has a bunch of other good stuff
in it
um I don't know I think I'm just going
to take the thing as exactly as it is
for a month and
see lot people seem people seem pretty
uh pretty interested in what he's up
to well the the thing is like
the thing that he's saying is in my mind
very obvious but for some reason is like
revolutionary to a lot of
people
um hold
Drive have you gone down the Paul
saladino Rabbit Hole yet or something
geez the what Al Saladin he's like this
Instagram Tik Tok YouTube guy was like
all about like oh you got to eat animal
based and Seed oils are bad for you he's
like it's like RFK Jr without the
vaccine
[Laughter]
commentary that's uh you know there he
he does have some salian points and I
agree with him on certain points uh I
don't know I'm personally like I'm
person I'm very happy to see I'm very
happy to see our food supply get up
close Lookout everyone everyone agrees
with RFK Jr until he gets to the
vaccines no no until until until it gets
to actually changing something whereas
where in the the uh egg Lobby and the
food Lobby are going to step in and say
uh by the way this is going to wreck our
profits the thing with
like the thing with the vaccine stuff is
I actually kind of get it because like
the messaging around those was just not
what it should have been you understand
he's he's not just anti-id
vaccine he he says that now but he's
like he's been part of the antia
movement since the N late 90s so to him
it's just like if you ask him what is a
safe vaccine he'll like pivot because he
doesn't want to like tell you like no he
actually also believes the chick andox
vaccine isn't
safe yeah that's and he and he like he's
like one of the epitome he's one of like
the the defining examples of of uh
believing in correlation is
causation at all times
yeah I guess my biggest issue is is that
sort of logical fallacies are at the
root of of these
things I think like generally Whole
Foods are better for you like that that
is like yeah that that is like
undoubtedly I think that is just
undoubtedly true like like not
fundamentally right like you could in
theory you could probably engineer
something that's way better for you like
whatever the is being engineered now
probably isn't good no it's also
confusing because agriculture has
changed over the last century yeah where
a lot of foods have been bred for
certain qualities like the reason why I
prefer I generally don't eat dried fruit
is because you can cram a lot more dried
fruit into you which will spike your
sugar your blood sugar and if you have a
whole fruit you're more likely to get
full faster because there's like more
just more stuff in it well that depends
as well on satiety right like for me I
generally have very low appetite so the
more calorie Den stuff is the
better and you're you're unique in that
in that regard no a lot of people like
basically anybody who anybody who's like
anybody who's like the skinny guy for
most of their adult life will be like
that yeah I'm like that I've been skinny
my my whole life mostly and like I
prefer to
eat you know it actually took like it
took quite a lot of like work and
research to figure out how to like I
mean I put
on well when I when I got to 190 that
was 50 lbs over my like adult weight for
most of my life
right I'm trying to gain was for like
long time man I me while was like
disgusting like I'd have like a 1 1600
calorie milkshake for dinner there were
a few months where I was having like
four or five Donuts a day I mean that's
not a good way of doing it the next best
thing I came up with I came up with a
th000 calorie hot chocolate recipe
that's mostly just heavy cream but then
it's also questionable whether heavy
cream is great for you so
uh it's a question whether anything is
great for you in sufficient quantity
learn that's where the heavy metals are
they're in the milk also by are these
are the type of people who are also like
very Pro raw milk like they don't that's
[ __ ] stupid that's that's actually
just straight up stupid that's the thing
like you dig in it's like on the surface
like yeah we should care about the food
we should care about the quality of the
food that's going into us and then you
dig a little bit further and you're like
ra will just that can just [ __ ] kill
you they end really they end up leit
really quickly yeah let me let me you
don't grow up drinking that like that
can just kill you no a quick no no a
quick aside a quick asside on raw milk
uh you know few people have have spent
sufficient time in the hospital to see
sufficiently sick people this was you
know a tertiary care hospital where the
sick sickest people go this uh infant I
don't know he's like six months old was
transferred there from a different
hospital because his level of care were
too high they had him fully sedated he
was not conscious and on a bunch of
fentanyl a bunch of other pain meds and
and and again completely sedated and uh
yeah he was waiting dialysis because he
had no kidneys and uh he was almost a
multi-or failure because his parents fed
him a raw goat milk that's
incredibly baby yeah it had infect C col
go figure which is actually really
common in yeah that'll kill you yeah I
got a from um I think from chicken or
something one time and it was the
sickest I've ever been
well [ __ ] you up and now you can't
yeah that was one of yeah that was
probably one of the things I me I had
food like bad food poisoning three
times oh this is this is actually
working this refactor is actually making
sense everyone's gonna hate me but it's
gonna make
sense I'm very proud of myself right now
proud of you too I mean a lot of a lot
of these crazy things that go around
like they have just like the tiniest
brain of Truth to them but then it's
just like they just go way overboard
right y because it's like yeah people
like I like guarantee back in the day
people had way stronger digestive
systems than the average person today
just died they got sick no no raw raw
milk was always a problem it it
the pasteurization in general care for
the quality of of uh food manufacturing
facilities through the lady 1800s to Mid
1900s like had a big impact on how we
live today there's like no like it just
it just killed some people the people
that didn't kill probably do no no no no
before people died now people don't die
because we actually like have safety
standards right there were other things
too like a high Baseline of death in
general from various things so you know
it was like you die of this or you die
of that and it's actually fairly common
still I I I know that fact Boy Slim song
you die a little bit this a little bit
of that the one Christopher walking I
know that one too that was a fun thing
to find out in the hospital that uh like
you got half the doctors that are
actually saving you and the other half
are just straight up trying to kill you
oh yeah
I you yeah it's it was crazy like it's
you know how it's like has like they're
Engineers that just write absolute
garbage and then they Engineers that are
Gods same thing with the doctor it's
like I had a couple that were really
good and a couple where it's like okay
you're going to straight up kill me get
out doctors allowed to have like bad
apples like KET Engineers I feel like
it's yes yes they are greated on
outcomes but uh it's like you have to
also like hope that you get like oh the
guys's having a bad day or they like got
all the relevant information from the
previous like your previous be really
good at being a doctor but a horrible
communicator and like where it's like I
could follow their exact train of
thought and how utterly stupid it was
and it's just like you've got to be
kidding
me yeah um it's like you just see their
exact train of thought in real time you
can just like see them making the stupid
inference in real time so part of that
also can be that they are ignoring you
as a patient like it's crucial to to
treat each patient as a individual
person uh it's very easy to SL look at
the look at the the stats basically look
at his numbers and you don't have to see
him you don't have to talk to him you
you don't have to understand him at all
so actually actually caring about
understanding a patient especially one
that's like unlikely to die let's be
honest you're uh I maintain that if I
had run a 500 Miles last year instead
of, 1500 I would have been
dead uh very you know very possibly this
is true and you are incredibly sick uh I
I lit I went in with 105 fever so yeah
that yeah that's um yeah that's pretty
consistent with your with your infection
interestingly uh I saw someone else on X
also said she had a the same infection
as well and she said it was really yes
really yeah I wonder if who was it uh
let me find her she said it was four
four uh four weeks and it was uh
incredibly awful uh pneumonia again with
the Michael plas pneumoni I hope this
wasn't like Stephanie or one of the
people I talk to I wouldn't be surprised
because I mean I got it at nurs the
incubation period should have been like
after
nervs yeah that would that would make
sense um if I search for uh M go
plasma let's see if I know this person
should come up here man how do I search
my how do I search my posts is there a
way to search my posts
that's why I'm being
stupid
micoplasma if we search on
newon yeah I was being stupid oh that
makes way more sense that one I'm just
I'm just stupid that's the stuff will
just kill you I it's particularly bad
because like even if you're in shape the
thing is you just don't not like you
just catch it even later
um yeah that's true basically by the I
basically had like one lung to breathe
with by the time I I caught it so
usually usually you get better like you
often just it often self- resolves right
I I personally think that you were you
had a a viral infection first and that
made you
susceptible it it opened your lungs up
to attack I mean it was like I was fine
at NS and that's the only place I could
have possibly caught it so I mean like
there's been there's been some weird
illness p passing through there's been
like two or three weird illnesses
passing through like I had like I
basically was sick for two months I I
was producing yellow snot and I was
coughing for like two to three months
you could have had the same thing I
could have had the same I could had a
milder case I don't know I've known
other I didn't have to go to the
hospital but I know other people that
sick for two
months marathon runner he just powered
through at some point at some well no
just like Diet Maybe like there's no
point of going to the hospital unless
you're like dying or something I'm like
to me there's no point of going to the
hospital unless you're like dying and
I'm not dying I'm doing fine I don't
have
cancer most doctors don't like most
doctors don't do much if if I'm curious
I'm going to see a specialist I have
enough physicians in my family I don't
really need to worry yeah I
mean that's what I thought and it almost
[ __ ] killed me I think me getting SI
but I think me getting sick may have may
or may not have caused an outbreak in my
kids daycare
so I was about to say I was about to say
few last words but then I like
yesik that one did
happen okay I still don't know how to
search [ __ ]
posts well step one you search step two
you you search to searching people's
just searching other people's stuff not
mine
caner is this running longer and longer
around not really
yet it's cool
though [ __ ] is that
V well these are the things that I've
actually
posted okay well these experiments are
going to run overnight if you find who
this is I just want to make sure it's
not somebody I talk to
oh yeah so here's speaking of
experiments here's an interesting
one
um
so so what's going on is apparently my
co my my Pokemon runs work better only
work if I have Tor shot comp pile
on oh that oh this this is the and
thenar mine too no like it's really
bizarre like
I'm not sure what I'm not sure what's
happened in this run because like
everything just a nose dive
but I'm not sure what happened to these
metrics just stopped cutting but
like it was really
weird like it was like going for like
six times longer and just wasn't
producing I'm like is what in the what
in the world is like
sensitive
to like the this parameter I don't know
uh it doeses seem a little weird it does
seem weird but like it's i' it's cor
it's like well I mean we'll see where
this experiment ends up something's
weird happening right now in it
but it's like it got like like it got
way fast it got way more
activity well let me see something else
what does Top Cut look like yeah it got
but I is it better or worse it's
debatable there's like a certain level
like it needs like
20% I guess needs like 10 like 1.5% it
needs like another 5% of Pokemon that
know cut before it like actually learns
how to use cut
properly it's
weird but yeah it's like I don't
know working better all right we'll see
what happens well these runs are going
nicely
uh we will
see we will see how smart carbs is we
will see how smart carbs is are you
riding your own carbs because like
that'd be nice you still got to write
Ray tuner for
carbs I don't suggest that um we have
our own cars we have our own carbs
wrapper that handles the spaces a little
bit
nicer
uh that's maybe uh
I don't know the the whole Ray tuner
seems if I know it's not good for like
what I know it's not like great for
arella but like for everything Elsey I
honestly don't just like all the crap
that they have all the dependencies I
just don't want to deal with it you
don't have to deal with it I'm just
dealing with it for
myself there's just I had to edit like
arib environment code all day yesterday
and it's just like God [ __ ] this is bad
the big problem the big problem I think
with Ray is everyone always Imports Ray
tune like that's and all that's always
unnecessary but people do it and I'm
about to do it probably
yeah you know the hyper pram stuff is
like you kind of don't need it
integrated well I guess you have the ray
cluster thing H you have the ray CL I
mean the ray it doesn't matter because
like I only I only have one workable box
right now anyways so I got to fix you
know maybe tomorrow we'll do the micro
code update finally that'd be good it's
not just m micro code it's like you try
to receip GPU like five or six I don't
think it's a receip I think it's just
straight up the BIOS
update maybe if there's I mean there's
also like GPU stress tests that you can
just run to see like what's if the GPU
is bad is it failing with Cuda ER is it
failing with um seg faults seg no it
looks no no it says it's a Psy but if
you scroll up it's a Cuda error
ah you got all this Cuda stuff going
on yeah it's I mean if you give me a GPU
I'm
gonna we
know all right that's weird that's all I
do it's weird because
in uh in the seg vaults there's a couple
of them that
do complain about
Cuda yeah so at 42 error 6 in lib Cuda
likely on cpu8 core 16 I think that's
proba oh yeah for the various folks on
YouTube and uh and twitch we're just in
the puffer Discord it's discord.gg
puffer you're free to join um we got
lots of new people around here building
cool RL environments it's a great way to
get
involved yeah I've said a million times
the whole time good thing you didn't
reveal your true identity
yeah I like I pretty much just stream
all the dev these days and I was deving
I was doing code review for bet at the
start of is so yo I mean why not there
are currently at least seven people on
uh on between twitch and that's awward
and
YouTube uh it's usually about what it is
if I'm doing something that's not
horribly boring
ironically when I get very deep into the
the dev where it's like there's actually
cool stuff to learn then it usually
pulls off I'm just hanging out
more this twitch chat is completely
different you know watch next yeah I can
I can hear the I haven't actually I
haven't been looking at the chat
intense oh no there's
a
see and there's someone
places I got to get the only thing is
the lighting in my room isn't good
enough to have um the green screen
doesn't fully work at night and the only
way to fix it is to make this ring light
in my face just ludicrously bright which
I don't feel like give me a tour of
Neptune give me a tour of Neptune while
we're here Neptune it's really nice show
me show me show me what you got so I
mean you got charts you got charts like
one right you got all your charts that's
what expect they they
display more data and they load
faster okay that's good and then you
have this nice dashboard view we can
just add whatever charts and then you
can just apply this dashboard to any set
of runs that you like and what I do is I
just group everything by Tex so here I
have this carbs run right I can just
enable car in instead of sweeps you can
just they're just tags yeah I just tag I
just tag groups of runs oh that that
that's perfect isn't this nice look how
easy this is right and now I have Paro I
got sweet progress I got all these
metrics uh and then like I can just turn
all these off and then I can go over to
like this one here which is 100 runs
right and I get this Paro front and I
can look at these runs and I like I can
have it for different environments I can
have it for whatever I want and
everything loads it's not perfect but it
loads a fair bit faster it displays 200
points by dult instead of 50 um it's
quite
nice yeah that and then like you get you
know your experiments here so like here
I can look at this one and I have all
the parameters like you would expect so
I can look at train
TR honestly you may have me sold on tags
it's pretty good and I do the exact same
thing now for wanb so what we're going
to do in the next update we're going to
drop support for wanb sweeps but we're
going to keep support for wanb because I
do the exact same thing in wanb with
tags the UI is just not quite as nice it
lags a little more and you don't get the
nice data download features that's one
of the really nice selling points is you
can just I can just download this entire
group as a data frame and like 10
seconds wait how do you do tags and wa
weights and biases they have a tags they
have a tags thing same as here they just
don't have like this nice dashboards
View and stuff that's really easy to
apply to tags it's a little laggier and
stuff I mean Neptune has fewer features
but they're like they're faster and they
work better
like what what features do you need like
what are what are
the I really like
the but in terms of like features that
are that don't exist in womi what are we
talking about like 100 gigabytes of
storage and no uh the main thing that
doesn't exist in W is the data download
that's their biggest
one no no no no sorry you said Neptune
has fewer features than oh yeah Neptune
the ones that's missing in Neptune is
like this is all they have for charts
they really don't have very many options
they don't have like I can't add custom
charts here like I would like to be able
to add custom charts and stuff so it's
pretty
limited let me see custom charts like
what are you looking for well one thing
I really want which I'm going to get on
a call with them and see if I can get
them to do this uh you should be able to
apply a a color palette to your points
because what I would like to do is I'd
like to do hot cold based on creation
time and then I can see in the Paro
front right like the more recent runs
whether they're on the front or not
stuff like
that I see what not to mention oh I've
received 100 messages today open the
vendor
popular no that's that's just half of
those are
spam is there a is there a dark mode
Joseph no there isn't that's the one
thing that everyone oh my God wait are
you sure
like the one thing everyone hates that
there's no [ __ ] dark mode okay how
could there not be I don't know care I
mean dark Mode's kind of useless but oh
can you
like dark one is not kind of
useless
you yeah here's the real you can upload
images
images that's enough for me can it can't
do tables look you upload do upload
image oh tables are a big one do can you
not do tables no you do I think you do
hold on tabl I mean I monitor they have
artifacts as well look well everyone has
artifacts another big question how's it
look Via
Mobile I don't know you know it's better
than it's got to be it has to be better
than not a table probably still awful
but uh no no the question is can you
upload a table Yeah It's gotta it's gota
look so like for Pokemon I you can add a
CSV it's an artifact yes that's f they
visualize the CSV well so Pokemon I
upload all the parties of every agent
every like you know periodically I think
you just and you can just add that as a
can't you just add that like here as
like a
Pam CU like they group nice into folders
and you just do like this is a table
it's not a it's not a parameter though
parameters are constant for the entire
run usually you can overwrite
them the but I it just is a chart it's
basically just is a chart and you get
the latest value here ah so it's not in
the right place I it's not I mean it's
not
perfect I think I think we said before I
think we said before about CSV uploads
would make way more sense this is kind
of cool they do monitoring here uh
what's the source code so they do your
source
code does that automatically Yeah well
yeah I look see we have our
score see this run and I go back to
ablations which you can add you can tag
it as a puffer fish which is the best
feature it's the best the best features
that you can tag as the puffer
fish weird you could actually you could
actually use emojis in names and it
doesn't crash it that was so funny that
WB bug no they didn't fix it he's like
yeah I'll get on it yeah I'll they never
fix anything no he he actually bies the
big issue W and biases is they've been
constantly changing their you like
breaking their U every
Friday they keep on sometimes fixing it
but not
often these guys are this is I've been
happy I'll support both as the thing I
just won't support w b sweeps I'll just
support uh sweep tags I did this for NYU
I did this for NYU yesterday a few days
ago in want here I'll show you exactly
what it looks like I would support want
I would support weights and bias sweeps
I actually would support weights and
biases sweeps if they didn't force you
into only two algorithms and then made
it so you could just bring in whatever
you want and they and you could like do
your own yeah but you can do you can do
that just like with like with tags and
it's easier yeah you can you don't want
like their API doesn't add
anything no but that that that's the
it's like you just want the convenience
of like oh let me bring in my own Loop
you just manage the server and that's
that it's just convenient if they have
it yeah but they don't it's not good any
like yeah your server well no I got I
mean I I got it to work I did it that's
not good I made the loop oh great I mean
the other issue is I have to like sync
all the code across all the servers
whenever runs that's the reason why I
was going with Ray is because like with
Ray I can just like say Boop oh take all
my code where' the thing go the task
okay so here
is here I set this one up for NYU like
you see they have they have all these
runs and then they have all these
metrics right and they can add stuff to
these
um but like it's the same thing in WB
it's just not as clean weird curve yeah
it's not as clean but yeah so that's it
oops that's
[Music]
name quick question
the I haven't got to the like
yes does are you sure this is not a is
this a real account real
person okay I didn't I did not talk to
this
person same I didn't talk to this person
either I didn't you it's actually
interesting you can search that you
could you could have a disease detector
actually disease
Wass you can search Queen of the Unicorn
you may have not been you may have not
talked to them but you may have talked
to someone who talked to them
exactly right like we're talking about
an Airi uh an airport hanger number of
people like it's not that contagious as
the thing it isn't but yeah droplets
drop of particles man it's not that
contagious droplets man how do they work
scon looking at pong is there much Tom
wait what are you trying to do with pong
Oh no just using that
the I'm using that for the templat to
write the scon because I haven't done
all the scon files look the same it's
just boiler plate I I I told for
it I haven't managed to cut that down
yet but yeah just tell GPT copy this
format
exactly oh okay and it'll do it fine you
it'll be functional take long you will
have to move one C def outside of the uh
the loop four step I think but you'll
see I can't tell it's going longer yet
but but like the like siong that c i
don't need to touch that one right no
that's compiled that's a compiled no no
that's ignore
that no don't don't touch that Stu so
that's what syon does is it takes the C
file and it injects it injects a bunch
of other [ __ ] into it and it will
produce like a 30,000 line file don't
touch
those oh so I don't need to copy that
all I got you you don't need to that no
it's way
simpler okay yeah what I was going to
ask was like the um I haven't had time
to go about like the actual like you
know learning part of things are we
writing Cuda kernels no or it's in py
it's in Python okay thank God so we do
we do deploy our tell you you have to
write your own CA curl we do we actually
do run our networks and see uh for the
site but we don't have Cuda kernels from
let me show you it's very simple so all
I have is there's this puffet Doh file
which is like a 500 line file all right
and this implements lstms coms uh linear
layers activations all the stuff and it
implements it exactly like torch does so
if you look at most of these things most
of our environments use standard
architectures uh some of them don't but
like here if I look at if I open pong. C
all right this has got a linear lstm
which is a linear layer followed by an
lstm that's the policy just make this
with from puffet and then you just call
this on the
observations and because it's all in C
the result of that is I can open up the
website and I can click on pong and this
is a neuronet playing pong in your
browser because it's just running the
weights and
see but we train in P George oh okay if
you have a fancy Network you know if you
have a really fancy Network like I had
to do for neural mo3 yeah there's a
little bit more work involved like this
is the MMO net right there's like a
little bit of stuff it's not that bad
though and like here this is the whole
network that's it that's the forward
pass for like a pretty damn fancy
Network and then the result of this is
neural mo3 policy runs in your browser
bad all right gotta I have
to I did the hard part already the hard
part was getting uh was getting the
implementations of the layers to exactly
match P torch that was a pain in the ass
but uh you know I wrote some tests and
it took some time and I did
it did you stop streaming on on X no if
I stopped it's because it crashed
you're back I think yeah you're
back I know I think I should go to bed
anyways it's like 10 something
typ oh yeah it's really laggy wow good
night yeah why do I have why do I have
six people watching me why do I have
nine people at least just like watching
me hang out and about RL I mean one of
them is me who was watch one of them is
me who's watching you like it's probably
how
anything probably I'm also watching you
on switch all right but I mean there are
some other people so for folks that are
there um I mean all this RL stuff it's
free it's open source you can check
puffer doai for demos join the Discord
right here this is where we're all
hanging out as you can see this is kind
of a routine thing um I'm also I post
all the stuff on X and if you want to
help us out for free star the repository
really helps us out
uh if you're looking to get into RL the
best way to do that is to just swing by
and start coding up a new environment
and get RL working on it end to end we
have like brand new people with no RL
experience coming and do this it's uh
and we just need to be able to Cod
that's about it I think that's going to
be it though for tonight I'm pretty
tired folks
um I me take care of yourself yeah I'm
pretty tired so I think I'm going to go
to sleep and then tomorrow when I get up
I'm going to do
we're going to look at these hyper pram
sweeps a little bit more uh I'm probably
going to start looking at some
curriculum SL exploration stuff on
stream we'll probably look at a couple
papers of that and fix a few puffer bugs
maybe work on a couple of our academic
collabs we'll see I really do want to
spin up the science side of puffer Moore
though so Spencer's not around and
Captain's not around but I'm going to be
onboarding them hopefully to that
um and I think that the next steps are
going to be to get get more of the
Baseline environments training faster in
wall clock time just via like hyper pram
sweep stuff and then using that fast
Baseline start modifying algorithmic
things and then rerunning full sweep so
like we will launch 100 experiments per
environment and then we'll launch like
10 environments so a thousand
experiments per algorithmic change and
if we can get all of those to run in
like single digit number of GPU
days I think even get that to run in
like three GPU days maybe and then we'll
be in a good
spot that's the
plan
yes agree yeah